I've been coming here since I was about
five years old and I walked through the
door down the hall there and seeing an
animal that size it really had a huge
effect on me and I know that's true for
many people
[Music]
there aren't a lot of organizations that
have the talent and capacity to do this
kind of work these mounts that were
taken care of are both scientifically
really valuable but also historically
important and so taking them apart has
to be done really carefully by people
who absolutely know what to expect and
because RCI has worked on so many
projects like this they're just total
Pros about it
[Music]
okay that's it each skeleton comes apart
slightly different
there's a lot of similarities between
this and other ones we've done but every
time we always find something new
or something else holding up one of the
new things is everything's plastered
together here and it doesn't mean it
hasn't happened in the past but they're
really plastered together it makes a
little bit more difficult because you
have to be careful when you separate it
off the steel you try and Chip the
plaster and you have to do without
breaking bone
it's not just the size or the number of
the fossils it's the fact that they also
get the Artistry that's involved here
too because you're having to think about
how you make something that's been dead
for 150 million years look like it's
alive
this Hall will look quite different when
it reopens the mounts overall will be
much more lifelike they'll represent
behavior in a way that they haven't in
the past so I think it'll be a different
kind of experience for visitors in the
big picture this project is happening
because museums like the Peabody remain
really important this is where
scientists get together to tell stories
to The Wider world and that's never been
more important than it is now that's
what it's about and so this is a chance
for us to update all of that and get it
right
[Music]